what's going on reject nation Greg Alba here
Andrew here I am so excited this is the one
III trailer I want to be on top of as possible
right now and that is the Last of Us part 2 e
through 2018 gameplay reveal trailer as we're
shooting this it dropped 1 minute ago this year
I officially got back into actual gaming and it
started with the Last of Us I would move first
time in years I was hooked on a game and all I
wanted to do was play it loved every moment of
it I am so excited for this right now I'm like
super super excited her last time we did a video
of it I hadn't played it yet alright you ready to
get to it buddy let's do is check out the gameplay
without one night to make a little
brown damn it little said he had a
shot or down went back home jumped
into bed 45 pistol under my [Music]
[Music]
I have told you amazing
graphics what's crazy [Music]
when I hate these things tell me about it
your old man really laid into me
today what happened another big
lecture about my patrols don't go here
don't go there it's funny how involved
he gets whenever you're scheduled to go out yeah
she's a but not quite the show
[Music] there's a lot more ethnicities two
weeks back together not gonna happen she say
something dude make it one week really hey
what took you so long boom here and I Deena
Jesse hey don't forget we leave first light to
get some rest yes sir yeah yeah such a day come
on don't you start with me okay I have a very
serious question for you how bad do I smell a
hot pile of garbage oh okay yeah you love it
[Music] every guy in this room is staring at
here right now you got your big cat what's her I
mean they're staring at you make out do it or not
maybe they're jealous of you
[Music] just a girl matheran [Music]
I think they should be terrified [Music] his
eyes are wide open oh no where's the asian guy
who wants her back take no prisoners oh here we
go [Music] can't believe this is game do wonder
if you're gonna play as Ellie more in this one I
love play zone intense part of the first game yeah
so many children
Water Street
got how terrifying this
may she guide you watching assassin's
creed birthday spread out remember the
other trailer someone was being hung
to you I love that in the game when
you go through like familiar parts like
like a garage but it's like a ruins of a
garage like this grass growing
everywhere and stuff love that
you got this alley you got this
Oh [Music]
[Applause]
she went into the grass that's right
al watch yourself kill burying women
in the first can now now you know yeah I
know yeah it's crazy to be watching some
feel like you're playing again well she came
through here double back so it guns the camera
works improved yeah like it's a lot more long
hand combat yeah way better it's like a lot
more action movie cinematic angle yeah with
when it comes to the following the movement
[Music]
Wow Oh tail I was wondering I thought the
arrow disappear yeah oh she has been doing
that listening stuff you know when you listen
ya laters just really good at the game so maybe
you have to do the same thing here that's
so scary dude though how the room is lit
I'm so impressed with the camera work
it's way better it was like the rate
of the first time buddy blood
which yeah it's like the details
they may get a health kit no just that one there
you go good job explosive arrow is how with that
said is that what it was I think it said explosive
arrow I rather were explosives always [Music]
can you feel it
Wow grab the arrows the arrows
[Music]
well sever she was thinking about the whole choose
what I think about you when they
make it he should be terrified
[Music] I am so jacked I'm not sure yet I'm sure
people let us know in the comments god I was so
into that it was so that 11 minutes flew right
by man 1 minute almost 12 that flew right by I
was so into that one thing the gameplay trailer
lost for more commentary throughout the reaction
so I feel like we said a lot of what we were
thinking the part that I was so impressed with
with this gameplay trailer of what they decide to
reveal here it was all le they hint you know it's
like Joel still around you've seen him in another
trailer it was mentioned here with whomever that
Johnny is this said your old man told me when
it yeah you have very protective over you or
something like that yeah see here there but this
whole trailer was very le focused you only play as
le for a small part of the first game that was one
of the most intense parts of the game especially
because she was still a rookie and so there's a
lot of fear and you're so invested in this story
and now that Ellie is a lot more advanced in her
skills it makes for a much more badass dynamic
cuz I feel like when you think of the last of us
gameplay you're gonna want to see some footage or
Joel and then you get Ellie instead and it was
just as if not more rewarding I think for sure
I love the updates they've made with the hand
hand combat the camera camera weren't easy is
so much more improved yeah that was one thing I
didn't even think they would try to do you know
one thing I really appreciate I mean there's so
much tension throughout the thing because again
how invested we all are in Ellie but every time
you think she's safe there's another amount of
you know bad guys come and also I like how there's
so many different escape routes that you can play
you can go under a car you can go through the side
of ya know cracks and name exteriors you kind of
like find your way out of these messes so I like
that they're giving you like fun puzzles solved
while at the same time giving you incredibly and
in comic when she did the explosive arrows I mean
yes I'm loving to the updates as I said just
explosive air ISM I'm so curious to see what
other updates they made with the weaponry I mean
when the camera angle follows them around every
motion she's doing it the cameras smoothly
following her and knows when to crash like
a wall yeah it's like a beautiful long shot that
enhances the experience every time every movement
she does if she's striking or ducking or getting
pulled in the camera follows each one of those
movements it doesn't just stay stationary and it
doesn't just crash in or zoom in or whatever when
she's getting hit or when she's hitting someone it
follows every little detail the camera angle will
shift depending on the intensity of the situation
in that action moment when I was watching this I
felt like I was playing the game again I really
felt like oh my god that's I feel when I'm
playing the actual game sure and some people might
disagree with me but I wouldn't even mind seeing
this in movies the way this is like films like no
I've seen the longshots how would just smoothly
just move so in a position to where you feel
like you're in total control but you're not at
a bad angle to where you feel like you're like I
can't see or I'm gonna get screwed over there and
someone's like kind of blindsides you it's like
it always feels like you're at a proper angle like
where you need to be and the attention to detail
on the violence too like we pointed out with the
arrow being stuck in her yeah a lot of games arrow
would just disappear or something but she went
on for a while and then she eventually subs like
pull it out that it find her attention to detail
and there's blood on it also too if you notice
she's gotten a tattoo on her right forearm yeah
I definitely didn't have that in the first game so
obviously I mean I would imagine this is a couple
a few years later what has to be several years
like yeah I mean she's obviously older matured
I mean she has it's like love romance yeah and
also they kind of pointed that in the first game
in terms of that there's like an after after you
beat the story mode there's a mission that takes
place before you know she meets up with Joel and
all and the fireflies and all them she does have
a love interest that's a girl her age so they
actually did hint at that you felt organic you
know even though we don't really you know know
too much about the story like just what we did
see it actually did feel organic and I really like
the chemistry between the two of them all you have
to tell me is lots of us part two and I'm sold
I don't need to know more about the story I'll
find out when I'm there cuz I trust the writers
good I'll be like yeah I'm gonna watch the store
I play the whole game yeah this was great this
is fantastic just take my money just take off
yeah I don't even care if I go in the negatives
I wouldn't even get the special special edition
or whatever I guess the next question is you get
to actually play as Joel at some point or is he
just way too old to play as now might even be
like reduced like how much Ellie was played in
the first game maybe that's how much maybe they
flip it yeah we're now flyby well with everyone
though plain is Joel free awesome yeah there's
gonna be plenty of Joel alright guys what do
you think of this gameplay trailer how awesome
does it look to you guys I'm excited as hell for
it you guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification Belka subscribe buttons
are kind of broken you could check out and zero
on the movie source channel a lot of great movie
coverage over there follow me egg or 7-eleven on
twitter and check out our patreon full like TV
show reactions weekly Q&A s music video coverage
would love to have you become a patron eject today